The solution to these problems is called gamma correction. We have two separate
wishes. We want to compute our renderings in a linear space, and we want to
compensate for the power curve of monitors when we're displaying. At its
simplest, the equation's just this. You take the computed channel value, you
raise it to the 1 over 2.2 power, and that gives you the value you need to
display. This value of 2.2 is called the gamma correction value. Older Mac
displays used 1.8 or so, but now 2.2 is the norm for all monitors. For example,
say we have a value of 1.0, 0.6, 0.2 in our linear compute space. We raise 1 to
this power and we get 1 back. 0.6 raised to the power gets 0.793. Finally 0.2
gives us 0.481. Notice how each channel changes by a different factor. 1.0
didn't change at all. 0.2 more then doubles. This is why color shifting can
occur if you don't gamma correct. Gamma correction is something that's applied
to the whole image just before display. If you try to do it yourself you have
to be aware of precision problems with your input data. For example, if you
have only 8 bits per channel coming in, you won't be able to get 8 bits of good
data coming out. The good news is that Three.js has gamma correction built in.
All you have to do for it is ask. One last detail is that when you look at a
color swatch or a texture on the screen, you're seeing the monitor's power
curve version of the data. If you want to use that data properly when computing
lighting effects, you actually have to raise each channel's value to a power of
2.2 before using it for anything, either making mipmaps or making images
themselves. Three.js uses an on-the-fly approximation, squaring the texture's
color when it is sampled. To sum up, whatever we see on the screen is in this
nonlinear gamma space. To use it in lighting computations, we want to make the
data linear. So we raise each channel's value to the 2.2 power. We perform our
lighting calculations, then at the end we go back to the monitor space by
raising to 1 over 2.2. Here are the corresponding Three.js calls. Some GPUs and
APIs have built-in capabilities for dealing with gamma properly. Unfortunately,
these aren't currently accessible through WebGL or Three.js. Internally in
Three.js, there's some approximation of gamma. So a value might be squared,
instead of raised to the 2.2 power, to bring it into linear computation space.
To see the effect of gamma correction, take a look at the demo that follows.